quand on m'a proposé de venir parler de
l'espace
la santé j'ai tout de suite été très
enthousiasmé en effet 2021 c'est une
année très riche en actualités spatiale
le deuxième vol de thomas pesquet
l'atterrissage du robot persévérance sur
la planète rouge c'était un timing
parfait
puis on m'a dit le thème de cette année
c'est la proximité à moi je travaille
sur l'espace donc c'est exactement
l'inversé le lointain l'isoler en
exploration spatiale
le but c'est justement d'aller là où il
ya exactement personnes je m'appelle
lucie campagnolo et je travaille pour
mais des skis et l'institut de médecine
et de physiologie spatiales et le cnes
l'agencé spatiale française
alors quand on pense passionne on pense
à quoi aux fusées aux astronautes au
satellite aux étoiles mais aujourd'hui
j'aimerais plutôt vous parler des
applications spatiales
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont des
applications concrètes qui prennent un
mou de technologie ou de savoir-faire
issu du spatial pour en faire une
solution pour nos problématiques sur
terre et en particulier j'aimerais vous
parler de la santé avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet je crois savoir que 90 %
d'entre vous ont actuellement un petit
bout de solutions spatiale dans la poche
ou dans votre sac à main alors je vous
évite de chercher il s'agit de votre
téléphone portable qui a une petite puce
gnss donc c'est le gps ou galileo pour
le système européen qui permet de donner
en temps réel votre position votre
vitesse et leur en s'appuyant sur une
constellation de satellites mais pour
aller un petit peu plus dans le détail
je vous propose de regarder les
objectifs de développement durable
les objectifs de développement durable
sont très importants ils ont été
ratifiée par 193 pays aux nations unies
pour s'unir et se fixer un objectif
global pour faire prospérer la planète
tout en la préservant
et en particulier l'objectif 3 s'appelle
santé et bien-être et le but c'est
d'avoir une couverture de santé
universel équitable et de qualité pour
toutes personnes vivant sur terre
et là le spatial a sa carte à jouer et
ne se sont pas juste des mots mais
vraiment des actions concrètes pour
aider à avoir la même qualité de soins à
toutes les personnes quelle que soit
leur localisation
je vous propose de vous imaginer en
guyane il fait chaud il fait humide
nous sommes dans un petit village à la
frontière avec le brésil
la ville la plus proche est à plusieurs
jours de pirogue pour rejoindre cayenne
il faut prendre l'avion
et dans ce petit village il ya un centre
de soins ça ressemble à une petite
maison avec un personnel hospitalier sur
place et ce par cette personne a pour
mission de soigner de dépister de
diagnostiquer et d'organiser les
rapatriements sanitaires de toutes les
personnes qui habitent dans la région
heureusement sur ce petit dispensaire
il y a une antenne satellite et cette
antenne permet de relier en temps réel
via internet
ce centre de soins à l'hôpital de
cayenne et ça c'est extrêmement
important il ya 17 centres comme ça qui
sont dispersés dans toute la guyane
puisque ça permet au personnel soignant
isolé d'avoir accès à des médecins
spécialistes
un deuxième diagnostic de consulter le
dossier patient de pouvoir remonter des
problèmes d'épidémie jusqu'à cayenne
avant que l'épidémie se répand sur la
guyane
ce sont des systèmes opérationnels qui
sont utilisés depuis plus de vingt ans
et qui sont extrêmement importants pour
résoudre des problématiques de fracture
sanitaire alors la fracture sanitaire
on connaît et on connaît
particulièrement en france
métropolitaine
je vous pose la question qui a renoncé à
utiliser des applications de
télémédecine parce que la 4g ne passe
pas bien dans le village
qui a renoncé à aller se faire dépister
parce que le premier médecin et à 1h30
de voiture et son rendez-vous et dans
six mois là aussi le spatial répond avec
des solutions concrètes
je vais vous parler des unités médicales
mobiles alors il faut imaginer une
petite camionnette où un camion et une
antenne satellite qui est installée sur
le toit du camion à l'intérieur de ce
camion il ya des instruments de
diagnostic et il ya un personnel
soignant
tout ça est relié en temps réel via des
télécommunications par satellite à
l'hôpital de référence
ces camions s'organise avec les mairies
pour faire des tournées et pour aller au
plus près du patient
l'idée c'est vraiment que c'est
l'hôpital qui vient à la rencontre du
patient pour offrir la même qualité de
soins pour tous le dernier projet que
dont je voudrais vous parler aujourd'hui
s'intéresse à une problématique
complètement différente et on va parler
des moustiques et en particulier du
moustique tigre alors je vous rassure
tout de suite c'est impossible de voir
les moustiques tiques depuis l'espace
par contre les satellites d'observation
de la terre qui s'y qui sillonnent la
planète 24 heures sur 24
permettent d'observer des choses
extrêmement intéressante pour mieux le
comprendre il faut s'intéresser aux
modes de vie du moustique
le moustique tigre il reste toujours un
peu dans le même endroit
c'est là où il se sent bien là où il
peut pondre où les températures sont
agréables pour lui et il ya de l'eau un
peu stagnante et toutes ces choses là
sont observables depuis l'espace les
satellites de météo permettent de donner
la température et les satellites
d'observation de la terre permettent de
voir la végétation et d'identifier des
poches d'eau stagnante par exemple des
bâtiments abandonnés ou des endroits qui
sont connus pour être remplie d'eau
quand il ya des épisodes de pluie grâce
à ce type de données
la direction générale de la santé le
cirad et marie des marquis avec le cnes
ont travaillé sur un outil qui s'appelle
arbres aux cartes ou et qui à
disposition de toutes les agences
régionales de santé et qui permet
de prédire la densité de moustiques type
de façon très précise à l'échelle
presque d'un quartier pour pouvoir
envoyer les organismes de démoustication
au bon endroit au bon moment
là encore c'est une application du
spatial très concrète qui est utilisé
tous les jours et qui permet de lutter
contre les maladies à vecteur qui sont
transmises par ce moustique
pour conclure nous célébrons en ce
moment les 60 ans du vol de youri
gargarine pendant une heure et 48
minutes
le premier homme est parti dans l'espace
quelques années après le premier homme a
mis un pied sur la lune et cet événement
a été suivi par des milliers des
millions de personnes quels que soient
leur nationalité leur religion leur
genre alors la prochaine fois que vous
verrez des astronautes sanglé sur leurs
capsules prêt au décollage
retenant leur souffle que vous verrez
les moteurs des fusées s'allumer le
compte à rebours raisonner sur le pâtir
c'est ça aussi ce sentiment d'humanité
la prochaine fois que vous verrez un
instrument se poser sur la planète rouge
les salles de contrôle plein à craquer
les opérateurs ne vont pas y croire et
explosant de joie
c'est ça aussi ce sentiment d'humanité
finalement la proximité de l'espace elle
est dans chacun d'entre nous elle est
bien chacun d'entre vous alors
continuons ensemble arrivé je vous
remercie de votre attention